[Music]
in love triangle news that's permitted
by ABG from BOC a man helped his new
wife marry her lover huh a new wife mate
what in India I'm [ __ ] confused how
do you know that's that's some Indian
show it just sounded Indian as yeah yeah
in what sentence did I have curry I
don't know I think in India similar to
China there's just the population so
huge that there's just a bunch of weird
[ __ ] happening but when it comes to
people marrying other people I feel like
marriage like that only happens in India
like the crazy stories only kind of
happen in it like a reincarnation
marriage but that one's more like Africa
and [ __ ] sometimes like it's like these
rare little gems that come out of Africa
or like they think their wife was
reincarnated into like the 6th year of
boy another married but I don't know
this is really good with getting on the
same plane of thought with the whole
country then that's nothing crazy well
she's really racist crossed my mind that
that was an India thing I think I just
play games now in my house just like
let's guess it let's get this lover a
woman that's been cool huh yeah because
if it was like a person got gang-raped
in the village India mmm but that's also
very common in the village areas of
India or all over the world but then I
think we just hear it so much because of
the population cuz there's just so many
so much more crime because there's more
people maybe possibly yeah because I
mean China has a ton of people but you
don't hear about like gang rape village
what you do here is like the village
coming out and beating down the dogs
dealers yeah because people are stealing
dogs to eat them yeah so that's a China
I would guess China yeah
ya know we're losing let in your fish
who does that
China sounds like China people passing
around a baby dolphin and the dolphin
dying Japan Japanese to put a Cove and
then they slaughter the dog [ __ ]
the bloody Cove oh man alright you're
real CEO you're right we could get it to
gia ya know yeah but that [ __ ] was
morbid yeah very true
it's by the way it's it's a not all
Japanese people eat off in it's just a
small little not all Chinese people eat
dogs it's just a small little town
that's true these two guys don't eat
dogs
no just chicken see go ahead that's very
progressive of you what I don't know I'm
trying to prove anything some [ __ ] like
what like I was like KFC it's DFC dude
one time my grandpa was like obsessed
with this beef jerky and he kept eating
it and he was like obsessed with it and
then on the packaging is a dog oh [ __ ]
it was a dog jerky that's what we think
cuz he got it from this like Asian
market all the time and it was like this
off-brand like there's no I never know
and then the kids are like I think this
is dog meat like because there's a dog
on it and it didn't say beef jerky
anywhere maybe maybe it was just the
logo maybe thinking like that like
sriracha with the rooster yeah yeah but
that's like the story of my family that
my grandpa got addicted to a dog Turkey
don't even keep eating it after you guys
yeah that's Asian for ya
I don't care it's delicious yeah they
don't give I don't care yes couple here
this 28-year old groom he married a 24
year old woman from a different village
and as arranged marriages there's an
arranged marriage
and so they didn't sign any legal papers
or anything it was just like a community
blessing type of wedding and six days
later that's when three men from the
bride's village came to visit and one of
the men claimed to be the woman's cousin
so the two other men they went into town
with a broom and the cousin stayed
behind with the bride that's whatever
but that's the real lover yeah so then
that's when the villagers saw that there
was this newly married woman with a man
alone in their home and so they went and
he started beating up the dude Oh even
though they it says it's our cousin yeah
yeah because they're just like you can't
a strange man can't be alone with a
newlywed woman that's wrong even if it's
family you can't talk to a cousin here
and then finally the woman came forward
and confessed that that was her old
lover but that her family did not
approve of him and that's why they
arranged the marriage with the groom and
so because of that the two had to keep
their love a secret and then when the
groom came over from the village he
found all this out he decided to help
her marry her lover so then the three of
them can live in harmony baffled friends
on himself maybe maybe he was like she
kind of busted homie if you want her you
could that's so nice of him super nice
that's super nice I also want to know
exactly like how is that panning out
because they don't go into more detail
like is he also involved maybe really
maybe he's gay and that's his beard
yeah and he's like hey this helps me get
out of this so I could do this cuz it's
not is India it's not India's not very
accepting of that right oh I'm not sure
sure I was just wondering you can leave
a comment let me know I'm not going to
know anything homosexual arranged
marriage is a beautiful type so
progressive but still so backwards at
the same time homosexual arranged
marriage oh I know I know my kid likes
Bryan but then you know what the kids
like I'm not gay mom hey we're being
progressive there's blondie 18 with my
girlfriend no not today
yeah so then they so finally the groom
called over the brother and the sister
of the wife because the wife's parents
they have passed and so the brother and
his sister had to approve of this second
wedding and then also he called the
lovers parents so they can agree to this
whole arrangement so everyone was more
respectful including the the community
and that's great baby it is yeah what
happened with that meeting and they're
like oh you guys are lovers and you're
okay sorry I was just doing looking out
you know right thing at the time thick
to them yeah the worst neighborhood
watch community ever
stranger the penis wait so we're gonna
vote on his wedding all right and then
they celebrate and after the wedding
they're all drunk like Steve the other
day I want to say
sorry you understand it's like your
drunk friend at the bar like when you go
out and this dude's hitting on you and
she's like yo you better stay the [ __ ]
away from her you got a date off and
you're like actually I kind of like it
okay hey you want you want to get with
my friend she likes you but yeah they're
just saying that just solution was great
for everyone involved because if they
wouldn't have came up to with the
solution and three lives would have been
destroyed does the girl stop the [ __ ]
both of them as a thing I want to know
like are they bringing this out like is
he just slowly gonna oh it's not
solution one guy has a dry dick one guy
has a really wet dick was it like
transition [ __ ] we're like you [ __ ]
this guy a little bit and slowly you
just stop [ __ ] this cardi [ __ ]
like living together it just sounds like
they were able to get out of like a
trapped situation yes like the guy was
like I'm not really feeling her anyway I
am eyeing this girl so maybe I could
bring her in and like we don't have to
live together but we're still married
for her family say I'm all there were
people just being happy I'm glad that
they worked out a thing where everyone's
happy very true but people in their line
win situation yeah and she wins the most
yeah sure I got the money from this
guy's family and then the sex from this
guy yep and she could be in the middle
of a Indian [ __ ] meat sandwich good for
them
good for them Congrats cam özil talk yay
you know we have we have we have fans
that are stuck in this stuff because
sometimes I read my you had a friend
your friend remember oh yeah remember
the Indian girl that was in that lived
at the I don't you met her at the other
apartment oh yeah but I would ask her
like so you don't ever like when you
they'll go out to drink you don't date
you even like keep it right because I
have to go home and man me know in my
mind she day was born - born here and at
first she's like honestly there's no
point because I don't it just like that
I know but like how he can do that for
her
your mom no because your mom doesn't
sound like that what is my mom sound
like no even when you just like to kinda
accent because I imitate the perspective
I feel you guys's soul and it's full
just like that I had a co-worker who was
in our arranged marriage and like she
was from India and she was an arranged
marriage there and I had a daughter and
I think she came to America and she
found a lover there and she liked to
hardly ever talk to the husband but he
was cool with it and like you and I was
like so arranged marriage that kind of
sucks anything get to marry the person
you fell in love with and she's like no
no if arranged marriage is a really good
thing and she really defended it because
she's like you're supported financially
here you don't know like if you're gonna
make it can't be cut off at any moment
yeah and like they're obligated to do
their part as a team yeah regardless of
yeah that makes it and so she was very
for it even though she didn't get what
she meant it she separated love and
marriage I guess that was Japanese
culture for the longest time yeah yeah
you get love from outside of the home
huh what like the person that you marry
you're not expected to be in love with
them it's just to make the family it
wasn't an affair it's like you're
supposed to have love from a
professional that can provide love or
someone just like if you're rich enough
then you get a girlfriend huh and then I
guess the girls get the [ __ ] end of the
stick because oh so it's just guys that
get to do that always right
it's like in Greek culture girls I think
it's like a plus if they do get love
from the like they do fall in love with
the guy that they're arranged with
[Laughter]
[Music]